niemand bleibt sitzen als volodomir
selenski vor die Kongressmitglieder
tritt vor ihnen steht ein Mann der für
die Zukunft seiner Nation und für die
Verteidigung ihrer Demokratie kämpft
bereits im Vorfeld wurde sein Auftritt
im Kongress mit jedem Winston Churchills
im Zweiten Weltkrieg verglichen und auch
der ukrainische Präsident spielt auf das
dunkelste Kapitel unserer modernen
Geschichte an
Russland greift die freie Welt mit allem
an was es aufbringen kann ähnlich wie
die tapferen amerikanischen Soldaten die
Frontlinie an Weihnachten 1944 gegen
Hitlers Truppen verteidigt haben halten
bei diesem Weihnachtsfest unsere
tapferen ukrainischen Soldaten gegen
putinstruppenstand
wie wichtig dafür die Unterstützung der
USA ist erwähnt selensky in seiner Rede
immer wieder auch im kommenden Jahr
sieht der us-haushalt weitere knapp 45
Milliarden Dollar an ukrainehilfen vor
ob der Kongress dem zustimmt ist noch
nicht sicher in den letzten Monaten
hatten mehrere Republikaner die
Zahlungen in Frage gestellt wohl auch
deshalb wandte sich selenski diesmal
persönlich an den Kongress
bei diesem Kampf geht es nicht nur um
das Leben die Freiheit und Sicherheit
der Ukraine oder irgendeine andere
Nation die Russland versuchen wir zu
überfallen dieser Kampf wird bestimmen
in welcher Welt unsere Kinder und
Enkelkinder leben werden
bereits am Nachmittag war der
ukrainische Präsident zu Gast im Weißen
Haus neben wertschätzenden Gesten
sicherte ihm Joe Biden die Lieferung des
modernen Patch wird flugabwehrsystems zu
bei der gemeinsamen Pressekonferenz
betonte der US-Präsident einmal mehr
Amerikas unerschütterlichen Beistand
ich möchte dass sie Präsident selenski
und alle Menschen in der Ukraine wissen
das amerikanische Volk wird stets an
ihrer Seite sein und das wird sich auch
nicht ändern wir werden sie unterstützen
solange es nötig ist was sie erreicht
haben ist nicht nur für die Ukraine
wichtig sondern für die ganze Welt
gemeinsam werden wir dafür sorgen dass
die Flamme der Freiheit weiterleuchtet
ihr Licht wird sich gegen die Dunkelheit
durchsetzen
am Ende seiner kongressrede überreicht
selensky eine Flagge die im Soldaten an
der Front mitgegeben haben sie soll die
Politiker stets daran erinnern dass das
Schicksal der Ukraine auch in ihren
Händen liegt
[Applaus]
den Auftritt selenskys
wie kam denn die Rede und der Besuch bei
den Menschen an
ja erst bachmut der Besucher der frontan
Washington die Ukrainer reiben sich
schon ein wenig verwundert die Augen was
sie ja Präsident denn alles so treibt in
diesen Tagen und die Hoffnungen hier
liegen natürlich auf der Lieferung
dieses patriot-systems dieses System zur
Flugabwehr denn das größte Problem in
diesem Land sind natürlich nach wie vor
die massiven russischen Angriffe auf die
Infrastruktur hier im Land und hier in
Kiew kann man auch den Eindruck haben
dass das den Ukrainern zunehmend
schwerer fällt diese Schäden dann auch
relativ schnell zu reparieren also ganze
Stadtviertel von Kiew fliegen abends im
Dunkeln wenn man an den Wohnblocks
vorbei fährt dann sieht man so einen
bläulichen Schein hinter einigen
Fenstern das sind dann die
batteriellampen aber die Menschen hier
die gehen ja auch in die Feiertage das
Fest in der Familie das wird hier von
den meisten am Neujahrstag gefeiert und
die Sorge da im Dunkeln im kalten zu
sitzen die ist schon sehr groß die USA
das ist ja oder die sind ja der einer
der wichtigsten Unterstützer der Ukraine
in diesem Thema Krieg es gibt
milliardenschwere Hilfsprogramme die
auch für die humanitäre Hilfe hier
genutzt werden das ist natürlich wichtig
für die Menschen aber zum anderen
liefern die USA eben diese Waffen und
das hat ja durchaus die Ukraine in den
letzten Monaten beflügelt mehr als 50
Prozent der Gebiete die die Russen seit
Beginn des Krieges erobert haben konnten
die Ukrainer zurückerobern den Menschen
hier reicht das aber nicht und auch der
Präsident hat ja immer wieder betont das
Ziel ist der komplette Rückzug der
Russen aus der Ukraine live aus Kiew
Anne Brühl vielen Dank
und wir bleiben noch in der Ukraine und
schauen auf die Lage der Menschen immer
wieder wird ja die Infrastruktur
angegriffen haben wir eben auch gehört
viele müssen ohne Strom ohne Heizung
ohne fließendes Wasser auskommen und in
den bis vor kurzem von Russen besetzten
Gebieten wie zum Beispiel in der Region
um Issum da kommen noch weitere
Schwierigkeiten hinzu wie eine Brühl
dort beobachtet hat hier ihr Bericht
Svetlana ist wieder zurück in die
Mission
bis September hatten die Russen den Ort
besetzt
isum sieht man noch heute nach der
Befreiung an was Krieg bedeutet
warum sie zurückgekommen ist will ich
von Svetlana wissen
wir sind hier geboren hier haben unsere
Eltern ihr ganzes Leben lang gelebt wo
man auch ist zu Hause ist es doch am
besten
das ist das Zuhause von Svetlana
russischer Raketen haben es getroffen
drei Tage nachdem sie mit ihrer Familie
fliehen konnte
das heißt ihr habt alles verloren wenn
man sich das hier anguckt
wir hatten alles und jetzt haben wir
nichts unsere Eltern haben das gebaut
ich und meine Kinder haben hier so viel
Arbeit reingesteckt und jetzt haben wir
nichts wir haben alles verloren
die Menschen in der Zoom haben gelernt
mit wenig auszukommen Wasser muss in
Kanistern transportiert werden aber auf
dem kleinen Markt im Zentrum gibt es
fast alles zu kaufen
aber es geht es sieht mit dem Strom
schlecht aus manchmal wird doch das Gas
ausgeschaltet
man sollte sich über nichts beschweren
an der Front ist es noch schwieriger
ja die Leute können etwas kaufen die
Rentner bekommen ihre Rente und
diejenigen die nicht arbeiten bekommen
Lebensmittelpakete alles ist in Ordnung
auch auf der Stadtverwaltung von Issum
gibt es an diesem Tag keinen Strom auf
dem Flur werden die Handys angeknipst
Anträge ausgefüllt es gibt Geld von der
Regionalverwaltung und auch vom Staat
aber ohne anhaltende internationale
Unterstützung wird das schwer glaubt der
Bürgermeister
denn ohne die Hilfe von internationalen
Partnern können wir das was während des
Kriegs zerstört wurde nicht wieder
aufbauen
Svetlana ist bei ihrer Tochter
untergekommen
im Hof fängt die Decke die sie aus den
Trümmern ihres Hauses gezogen hat trotz
allem ist sie sicher dass die Ukraine
bestehen wird
die Russen schaffen das nicht unsere
Armee gewinnt wir gewinnen
und dann kümmert sie sich um ihre
89-Jährige Mutter alles in Ordnung
Babuschka sagt sie
und die Situation wollen wir einordnen
und besprechen mit der Ukraine und
Sicherheitsexpertin Jana pulverin
Leiterin der Denkfabrik European counsel
und Foren relations schönen guten Tag
guten Tag die erste Reise von silensky
seit Ausbruch des Krieges führt nicht
nach Berlin nicht nach Brüssel sondern
nach Washington warum bei Washington das
Rückgrat für die Ukrainer ist Washington
war der Schlüssel um die Europäer an
Bord zu bringen um sicherzustellen das
Waffen geliefert werden sie haben die
erste rammsteingeberkonferenz für die
Waffen organisiert haben wahnsinnige
finanzielle Mittel bereitgestellt und
ohne man kann sagen ohne die USA wäre
die Ukraine verloren und heute kein
souveräner Staat mehr die Ukraine
bekommt von den USA jetzt auch das
Flugabwehrsystem Patriot aber
offensichtlich dauert die Ausbildung
daran auch ziemlich lange darüber haben
wir gestern gesprochen das heißt welche
Bedeutung können die Patriots dann
überhaupt jetzt für die Ukraine schnell
haben also schnell nicht das ist mittel
bis langfristig und es geht eben darum
die Flugabwehr der Ukraine zu stärken
jetzt die Möglichkeit der Ukrainer
russische Raketen die ja gerade in große
Maße die Zivilbevölkerung die Städte
getroffen haben vorher abzuschießen und
Lücken in diesem System die jetzt
existieren zu schließen aber es dauert
eben was heißt das wie lange also es
kommt darauf an die Ukraine haben sich
als sehr lernfähig erwiesen bei den
westlichen Systemen ich würde mal von
mehreren Monaten ausgehen wenn man es
richtig macht geht man eigentlich von
einem Jahr aus ich denke das wird
schneller gehen aber es ist wirklich ein
komplexes Unterfangen also können diese
Patriots dann im Grunde die Situation
diesen Krieg entscheidend entscheiden
verändern werden sie den Krieg nicht
schon allein deshalb weil der Ukraine
offensiv Waffen fehlen die Ukraine
deswegen ist selenski auch in die USA
Gefahren möchte Kampfpanzer möchte
schützen fahren Panzer und von den USA
vor allen Dingen attackens das sind
Raketen mit denen sie das russische
Territorium treffen können die USA sind
zögerlich und zurückhaltend
weil sie immer sagen es geht nur um die
Selbstverteidigung weil sie immer sagen
dass sie verhindern wollen dass die NATO
in einen Krie mit Russland Eintritt die
wollen quasi die Ukraine unterstützen
aber die NATO raushalten und das ist
auch Konsens unter den
NATO-Mitgliedstaaten trotzdem hat
US-Präsident beiden ja gesagt wir
unterstützen euch und silensky hat
gesagt wir sozusagen kämpfen weiter und
im Grunde muss man dann schon sagen
diese Unterstützung der USA was bedeutet
das dann für den weiteren Verlauf des
Krieges also unbedingt die Unterstützung
ich glaube es ist keine unbedingte
Unterstützung das haben wir in den
letzten 10 Monaten gesehen es gibt
Grenzen aber diese Grenzen haben sich
verschoben die USA sind ein Stück immer
weiter gegangen und wir in Europa sind
das auch also wenn wir uns die deutschen
Lieferungen anschauen man hat immer
entschieden was ist unmittelbar
notwendig was braucht die Ukraine jetzt
genau aber hat immer versucht diese
feine Linie einzuhalten dass man eben
nicht zu tief in diesen Krieg
reingezogen wird sie verweisen auch
immer wieder darauf auch gerade heute im
Handelsplatz dass das Baltikum Polen z.B
die deutsche Haltung in diesem Krieg die
jetzt schon angesprochen haben nicht
verstehe und es aus Warschau
beispielsweise immer wieder hieße
Russland müsse vernichtend geschlagen
werden um eine Eskalation weiter zu
verhindern teilen Sie diese Sichtweise
ich finde das persönlich schwierig ich
würde sagen was der Kanzler gesagt hat
wir müssen sicherstellen dass Russland
den Krieg nicht gewinnt das ist auf
jeden Fall auch meine Linie und ich
finde man muss es wirklich den Ukrainern
oder mit den Ukrainern gemeinsam
entscheiden was ihre Kriegsziele hier
sind ich verstehe die polnische Position
aber die realistisch ist das wird sich
in den nächsten Monaten zeigen das hängt
entscheidend davon ab ob der Westen
bereit ist die Ukraine so zu
unterstützen dass sie eben auch offensiv
weiter Gelände Gewinne machen können das
heißt in ihren Augen ist es richtig
abwägen zu gucken dass man nicht zu sehr
in diesen Krieg reingezogen ich würde so
eine Mischung vorschlagen zwischen der
polnischen und der deutschen Variante
ich würde sagen wir können durchaus
etwas mutiger sein und z.B auch die
Marder und die Leopard eins über die so
viel diskutiert wird schicken ich
persönlich wäre auch für eine
europäische Leopard 2 Initiative sagt
die Ukraine und
sicherheits-fabrik European counsel und
von relations vielen Dank